And the closer that theta
is to the approximation, the higher the probability to see the corresponding value of Y.
And that's a pretty
significant improvement over using a single control Qubit.
This is in fact the phase
estimation procedure when we choose to use two control qubits.
And what we'll do next is to generalize this
procedure in a natural way, where we don't stop with
just two control qubits
but we use however many
control qubits we choose.
And what we'll see is that by
generalizing the procedure, by adding more control qubits, we'll be able to get more and more
accurate approximations of theta. And that will be the general
phase estimation procedure.
In order to generalize the
phase estimation procedure from two control qubits
to however many we choose, we're going to need to understand
how the quantum Fourier transform is defined for other dimensions.
And we're also gonna need to discuss how it can be implemented
with a quantum circuit.
Here's the definition of the
quantum Fourier transform when the dimension is an
arbitrary positive integer N.
Here we're thinking about this operation as being an operation on a system whose classical states are
zero up to N minus one.
And here the matrix that
describes this operation has been expressed using
the direct notation.
We can also describe it in terms of its action
on standard basis states, just to connect it with
what we already saw when N is equal to four.
So here's what it looks
like when N is equal to one, which isn't a very interesting case.
Here it is for N is equal to two, and you'll notice what we get in this case is a Hadamard operation.
Here's the quantum Fourier
transform for N equals three.
For N equals four, which
we've already seen.
And for one last example, here it is when N is equal to eight.
Just like we had before
for the N equals four case, These are the matrices that we associate with the discrete Fourier transform
for each of the dimensions. But we call it the
quantum Fourier transform when we want to think about
it as a quantum operation.
Sometimes by the way, the leading factor of one over the square root of N is not included when we think about the discrete Fourier
transform as a matrix,
but we need that factor here to make sure that we get a unitary matrix.
There's also sometimes a minus sign in each of the exponents, but not always.
It's basically just a personal preference that doesn't change the fundamental
nature of the transform.
But in any case, we'll define the quantum Fourier transform as it's written here on the screen.
There's a very useful shorthand
notation that's common and we'll make use of it
a bit later in the lesson.
And that is to define a
complex number omega N, like we have here.
Specifically as e to the two pi I over N, which can also be written
using signs and cosines
as we have right here. Sometimes we call this
number an N through of unity because when we raise it
to the power N, we get one.
Here's a figure that shows a few examples.
Omega one is equal to one, omega two is equal to negative one, and omega four is equal to I.
In general to get omega N, we can imagine slicing up the unit circle into N equal size pieces like it's a pizza being shared by N people
and omega N is at the
corner of the first piece, assuming that the other corner
of that piece is at one.
So in particular as N
gets larger and larger, the pieces will get smaller and smaller, and omega N will get
closer and closer to one.
And now if we use that notation we can express the
quantum Fourier transform in a slightly cleaner way.
Sometimes this notation
helps to keep things simple as we will see happening
a bit later in the lesson.
There's an efficient quantum
circuit implementation of the quantum Fourier transform
when N is a power of two,
which we'll now take a look at. Although we tend define the
quantum Fourier transform for any dimension N,
we're only gonna need it
in the case that N is a power of two, in order to generalize the
phase estimation procedure.
The implementation will make
use of controlled phase gauge which are depicted as we
have here on the screen.
They look like two
controls connected together along with a number which
is alpha in this case.
And the action of this gate is described by the matrix that's shown here.
These are literally
controlled phase gates, meaning that we have a control Qubit that controls a phase gate.
We saw phase gates way back in lesson one.
But for phase gates specifically, it doesn't actually matter
which Qubit is the control and which is the target.
And we saw that in lesson two, for the specific case of a Z gate.
And now that we have that notion, we can move on to how the
quantum Fourier transform can be implemented.